(slow dreamy music)
- People often say,
“BANDALOOP is death-defying!"
No, we're not.
What we do is life-affirming.
It celebrates the human spirit,
and grace and beauty and courage.
I'm not a daredevil.
I am a dance-maker.
(slow dreamy music)
BANDALOOP is a dance company that,
for 25 years now, has
been merging the worlds
of rock-climbing mountaineering
with concert-stage dance.
And bringing these worlds together,
we're able to dance in the
mountains or on buildings,
but in ways that activate those spaces
in unusual and wonderful ways.
(slow music)
(upbeat music)
Hello, hello.
I gotta give everyone hugs now.
It takes a lot of work to
make a dream into reality.
Doing the hard work,
finding the right people,
practicing, failing,
failing, failing, succeeding.
Having the tenacity to keep going
and trying to make something
that's sort of an idea, real.
The newest member of the
company is a young woman
named Virginia Broyles.
- Since I was a kid I
was always interested
in how people moved and
how to move my own body.
- Double, two rock, two, check.
- [Virginia] The more I
learned about BANDALOOP,
the more it made sense to me,
because I'm not losing any of the dance
that I love so much, I'm
just getting to do it
in this other relationship to gravity.
- [Amelia] I picked her because
she has a really high
capacity to learn fast,
take movement into her body,
which is sort of like what I
call a physical intelligence.
- The rotation and the
loft and jumping and
all these things were
really exciting and fun,
and then the next step is
like going on a building and,
I was like, oh yeah, I really wanna do this,
and then the voice is like, okay,
but is being on a building
gonna just be way too much?
- Dance your dance, dance with each other.
- [Virginia] I definitely feel adrenaline.
Walking up to the wall
before performances,
I get like really antsy
and excited and nervous.
- [Woman On Walkie-Talkie]
Get in your places, go.
- [Virginia] But once
something's been rehearsed
and you get that practice time in,
I guess my goal is to achieve
the state of non-thinking.
That's the ideal and
that's the most exciting
because it just feels like pure enjoyment.
- [Amelia] There you are,
hanging off the skyscraper,
and people look up and suddenly
there's a stage, there's
art, there's beauty,
there's grace, there's power in this site
that you overlook every day.
(upbeat music)
(electronic music)